هل انت مشاهدي العزيز في حيره من امرك لم
تحسم امر شراءك بيت العمر او شراءك بيت
العمر سواء كانت بيلا باحدى المدن الجديده
او امتلاك الشقه في احد الاحياء الراقيه
هذا القرار يعتمد على اسس كثيره خاصه ان
منزلك يعد استثمارك الخاص فلابد من التاني
عند الاختيار بين المعروض
او بين العروض المتاحه
اعتبار تغير ظروف الاقتصاديه وزياده كلفه
الحياه الاساسيه
التي
اصبحت
[موسيقى]
الينا بعد قليل الخبيره العقاري والمستشار
في تطوير المشاريع اسماعيل الحمادي سيكون
معنا لكن خليني اقول لك بانه اختيار البيت
هو احد اهم الامور التي من الممكن
تاثر على حياتك كلها مستقبلت كامل على
فكره هذه المشكله ستكون مواجهه انه
تختارين بيت كبير ولا بيت صغير اربع غرف
خمس غرف عشر غرف تحسين انه توسعين لكن في
بعض الامور ما تحتاجينها بالفعل بدي اقول
لك وعلى حسب يعني الفتره اللي انت فيها
بحياتك لما يكبروا الاطفال ويخرجوا من
البيت ما في داعي لبيت استاذ اسماعيل
الحمادي صبحك الله بالخير صباح النور
نختار يعني الاوليين كانوا ياخذون البيت
كبير اليوم احنا هل بحاجه الى كل هذا
البيت ولا بحاجه الى بيت صغير وشقه صغيره
وانتهى الموضوع ايهما افضل للاستثمار
للاستثمار ناخذ الموضوع بشكل اخر
الاستثمار انت ما راح تسكن فيه غيرك راح
يسكن فيه فانت تشوفه بنظره المستاجر
الملائع الماليه اللي هو فيها حلو النمط
الحياه اللي هو حابب يعيش فيها يعني انت
اليوم انا داخل على الاستثمار لازم اكون
عارف الموقع اللي انا بستثمر فيه الوحده
الموقع ونظره المستاجر لهذا المكان
والاطلالات اللي موجوده يعني انا اليوم
اذا على اطلالات مائيه او على اطلالات
خضراء خلينا نقول غير لما انا اكون على
اطلاله اطلاله شارع او بنايات افتح
البلكونه وما اشوف غير بالنسبه لبيت العمر
أنا بالنسبه لبيت العمر انت
تبني للمستقبل تبني لا مدى 20 او 30 سنه
مستقبلا فانت عارف
احتياجات العائله عندك عارف كيف نمط
الحياه اللي انت بتعيش فيه اليوم
خلينا نقول الدارج ان العوائل تكون صغيره
فملمومه على غير الثقافه اللي كانت موجوده
انتهت انتهت ثقافه انه الواحد يشتري بيت
ويفضل الان شقق ولا مازال يعني سوق الفلل
خلينا نقول او المنازل اللي فيها ثلاث غرف
فما فوق ما زال مطلوب لانه على الاقل يعني
لما يكون في ولدين او ثلاثه ولساهم صغار
بحاجه لشخص لبيت كبير يعني
ومدى التزاماتي انا اليوم بامكانياتي في
في شراء او بناء البيت هذا اليوم احنا
مقبلين على
يعني نماذج جديده من اسلوب الحياه خلينا
نقول فاليوم كل واحد يفصل اسلوبه على قد
حاله خليناه عشان ما يلتزم في التزامات
اكبر منه لكن
انتهاء هذه الموضه لا هذه لان هذه موجوده
اصلا مش موضه طيب خليني اسالك يعني
اسماعيل اليوم
ربما احنا تنازلنا ما كان سابقا بالنسبه
للحوش او البيت العربي الاولين كان عندهم
حوش هذا الحوش مهم موجود اليوم ربما تنازل
جيلنا عن هذا الامر البعض قد يرى بانه
المجلس او الديوانيه لم تحد ضروريه في
الشارع الواحد لربما تلاقيه اكثر من واحده
فبالتالي انا استثمر هذا المكان بانه
عيالي يسكنون او اسرتي هل راح تتغير ايضا
نظرتنا لهذه المتطلبات ونروح الى التاون
هاوس او البيوت الصغيره نرجع مره ثانيه
للثقافه
خلينا نقول في الخليج الثقافه في الخليج
كانت على اساس ان التواصل الاجتماعي ترابط
الاجتماعي في السابق ما كان فيه يعني هذه
الثوره من وسائل التغيرات اللي موجوده في
الحياه الواحد منا كان
يسكن ويعيش مع
الوالد مثلا في نفس البيت ما يفكر انه
يطلع صح اليوم متطلبات الحياه تغيرت صار
الواحد فينا يفكر في الاستقلاليه يفكر انه
كيف يكون مستقل
الحياه اختلفت ايضا الان الظروف الحياه
اختلفت الجيل الحالي ما يقعد في البيت
المجلس كان مفتوح من العصر الى الليل
اليوم الوقت اتغير واحد بيطلع بيعمل رياضه
ولا بيروح بيتسوق في المول ولا حتى يعني
اصدقائه موجودين اصلا في بيئه مختلفه
تماما عن الحاره اللي كان نفس السؤال بسيط
قبل ما ننهي معك هل الشقه اسهل للتاجير من
المنزل
كل وحده في سوق معين
سوق الشقق يعتمد على نوع الشقاق والمساحات
والاطلالات الفلل تعتمد على المنطقه وعلى
الحاره والخدمات اللي موجوده ومجمع كان
مغلق ولا كان مفتوح هاي كلها يعني
اشياء تؤثر على نوع التاجير نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك المستشار في تطوير المشاريع
والخبير العقاري اسماعيل الحمادي على هذه
بالعكس
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات